- [Woman] It is 1999 and I
am attending a residential
high school, there's girls'
dorms, there's the guys',
and the hormones are real.
There was a guy, we were both students,
we started hanging out,
along comes November,
we start making out,
but then December comes,
and there's like a week left
of school before Christmas
break and keep in mind, this is 1999.
Y2K is everywhere.
- [Reporter] When the
ball drops New Year's Eve,
everyone is preparing for the world.
- [Reporter] Computers gone haywire
could mean shortages of
food, water, and electricity.
- [Reporter] They're prepared to survive
no matter what happens.
- [Reporter] The end of
the world could be soon.
- [Woman] I seriously believed it.
Bombs going off from all the
hidden silos in the world.
- [Reporter] Security
officials are believed to be
on the biggest alert since World War II.
- [Woman] At that time, you
didn't really fact check,
you just believed.
With that came a fear I
could possibly die a virgin.
- They're making too much out of it,
it's not gonna be anything.
- [Woman] In study hall one
night, I actually sent him
an email that was like, you
know I was thinking about this
and we have a week left before
we have to go home for break
and maybe we should, you know,
take care of it before, you know.
(explodes)
The world ends.
Kinda sarcastic, kinda not, but
he said okay, let's do this.
Some of our favorite makeout spots
were these low bushes near the library.
Let's see, oh there was a graveyard.
(laughs)
It was pure teenage horniness.
I mean, it could have been Fort Knox
but there's horny kids and
they're away from their parents,
it's going to happen.
We escaped the dorms
and we found this tree,
had some awkward petting,
looking around, darting around,
making sure no one's looking,
'cause this is the late
'90s, everything was N'SYNC
and Backstreet Boys, so you
expected to have him show up
with a rose and there to
be this earth-shattering
kind of experience and then it happened.
It wasn't great and it wasn't bad
but there were the sensation
of having tree roots
and branches pressed against your butt
isn't exactly romantic
and like kinda laid there in silence.
That was it.
Went home for Christmas
break, more people watched
that countdown than ever,
everyone young and old was like,
oh, are we about to die?
But everything worked
out, we're still alive.
And I continued our
relationship in earnest.
There's not gonna be this huge explosion
and everyone will know about it,
don't put too much
pressure on it happening,
make sure you're ready, make
sure you want it, go for it.
(bells chiming)